2020 ELECTION.
>> DREW GRIFFIN, THANKS SO MUCH.
IN A RELATE STORY, THE THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY IN THE UNITED STATES,
IN NEW MEXICO TODAY, A JUDGE
REMOVED A JANUARY 6th RIOTER AND
COWBOYS FOR TRUMP FOUNDER, COY
GRIFFIN, AS A COUNTY
COMMISSIONER BECAUSE OF HIS ROLE
IN THE ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
GRIFFIN HAD BEEN CONVICTED OF
TRESPASSING EARLIER THIS YEAR.
TODAY'S RULING STATES HE
VIOLATED A CLAUSE IN THE 14th
AMENDMENT TO THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION BY PARTICIPATING IN
AN INSURRECTION AGAINST THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
GRIFFIN IS ALSO BARRED FROM
SERVING IN ANY FUTURE STATE OR
FEDERAL ELECTED POSITION.
THIS CONSTITUTES THE FIRST TIME
THAT AN ELECTED OFFICIAL IN THE
UNITED STATES HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM OFFICE FOR PARTICIPATING IN
THE JANUARY 6th RIOT OR
INSURRECTION.
IT'S ALSO THE FIRST TIME A JUDGE
IN THE UNITED STATES HAS RULED
THE EVENTS ON THAT DAY WERE IN
FACT AN INSURRECTION.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS, PETER
WAYNER, FORMER OFFICIAL WHO
SERVED IN BOTH BUSH
ADMINISTRATIONS AS WELL AS UNDER
PRESIDENT REAGAN.
HE'S ALSO THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
"THE DEATH OF POLITICS, HOW TO
HEAL OUR FRAYED REPUBLIC AFTER
TRUMP."
PETER, THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
LET ME START BY GETTING YOUR
REACTION TO ALL THIS NEWS ABOUT
APPARENT MALFEASANCE IN GEORGIA.
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR THE
INVESTIGATION TO COME THROUGH.
THE REMOVAL OF THIS NEW MEXICO
COUNTY OFFICIAL WHO WAS A
RIOTER.
I REMEMBER WHEN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY USED TO TALK LOT ABOUT HOW
THEY HATED VOTER FRAUD.
THIS WAS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I DON'T HEAR ANY REPUBLICAN
OFFICIALS TALKING ABOUT THIS
TODAY EXCEPT FOR POTENTIALLY LIZ
CHENEY AND ADAM KINZINGER.
>> I REMEMBER THOSE DAYS TOO,
AND THEY'RE A LONG TIME AGO.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS BOTH
SHOCKING BUT COMPLETELY
PREDICTABLE.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, THIS
CURRENT VARIATION OF IT,
ITERATION OF IT, IS A NEOLISTACH
PARTY.
THERE ARE NO BOUNDARIES, NO
GUARDRAILS AND NO PLACE THEY
WON'T GO.
AND SO WE SEE MANIFESTATIONS OF
THIS HERE, THERE, AND
EVERYWHERE, AND THEY COME UP ON
A DAILY BASIS.
BUT THE FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT'S
GOING ON IS THIS IS AN ATTACK ON
TRUTH, AN ATTACK ON DEMOCRACY.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT MORE OF
THIS.
>> JUST TO UNDERLINE, THIS IS
NOT PARTISAN.
YOU'RE A CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICAN.
THIS GUEST SPEAKER WHO WAS
FEATURED AT TRUMP'S RALLY THIS
WEEKEND IN MY HOME COMMONWEALTH
OF PENNSYLVANIA, CYNTHIA HUGHES,
TRUMP INVITED HER TO SPEAK TO
THE CROWD.
HE'S A LEADER OF A SUPPORT GROUP
FOR JANUARY 6th DEFENDANTS,
INCLUDING HER NEPHEW WHO WAS A
CAPITOL RIOTER.
>> HE WENT TO THE NATION'S
CAPITOL TO HEAR HIS PRESIDENT
SPEAK.
HE DRESSED IN A SUIT AND TIE AND
HIS FAVORITE HAT.
TIM WANTED TO TAKE PART IN WHAT
HE THOUGHT WAS GOING TO BE A
HISTORICAL EVENT.
INSTEAD, HE WITNESSED THE HORROR
SHOW.
>> WELL, SPEAKING OF HORROR
SHOWS, HE IS HER NEPHEW, THIS IS
HIM.
HE'S A NAZI SYMPATHIZER.
HIS CASE WENT VIRAL AFTER THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT RELEASED
PHOTOS OF HIM SPORTING THIS
DISTINCTIVE HITLER MUSTACHE.
ONE OF THE AUNT'S COMPLAINTS IS
HE'S BEEN HELD IN JAIL SINCE
MID-JANUARY, 2021.
SHE DIDN'T MENTION THE JUDGE WHO
IS A TRUMP APPOINTEE IS AFRAID
HE'LL GOING TO TURN HIS RHETORIC
INTO ACTION.
HE HAS SAID THINGS LIKE, QUOTE,
HITLER SHOULD HAVE FINISHED THE
JOB.
WHY GIVE THIS WOMAN AND HER
HORRIFYING NEPHEW ANY SORT OF
PLATFORM?
>> WELL, BECAUSE I THINK DONALD
TRUMP IS DERANGED.
I THINK HE'S A SOCIOPATH, AND
THIS IS HOW SOCIOPATHS ACT.
I THINK HE'S GETTING WORSE SINCE
THE ELECTION.
BUT THAT'S NOT SURPRISING.
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN WHO DONALD
TRUMP IS.
I THINK THE KEY STORY, I WOULD
ARGUE THIS IS PROBABLY THE KEY
POLITICAL STORY OF THE CENTURY,
IS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY FELL IN
LINE BEHIND DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT
IT.
AND WHY THAT'S HAPPENED IS A
LONG AND COMPLICATED AND DARK
STORY.
BUT THERE IS PART, A LARGE
PARTICIPATE, A MAJORITY OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, THE MAGA DAYS,
WHICH IS, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
AUTHORITARIAN IN THEIR
TENDENCIES, THEY'RE ACTIVATED,
THEY'RE AGITATED, AND THEY FEED
ON THIS STUFF.
TRUMP UNDERSTANDS THAT.
HE'S OUT OF TUNE WITH THE
COUNTRY, THERE'S AN EXHAUSTED
MAJORITY, MOST AMERICANS ARE IN
FAVOR OF DEMOCRACY, IN FAVOR OF
DEFENDING TRUTH.
IN TERMS OF THE BASE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, IT'S HARD TO
OVERSTATE HOW RADICALIZED IT IS,
AND YOU SEE IT TIME AND AGAIN,
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONSUMING THE
STUFF.
ONCE UPON A TIME, THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AT WORSE WOULD HAVE BEEN
SILENT, BUT NOW PEOPLE ARE
CELEBRATING THESE KINDS OF
PEOPLE.
>> YEAH, AND I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW, LAST WEEK, YOU TALK ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR, THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR.
HE WENT ON A WILD SPREE ON TRUTH
SOCIAL.
LOOK AT THIS POST THAT TRUMP
RETRUTHED.
THE WORDS, YOUR ENEMY IS NOT IN
RUSSIA OVER THE FACES OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT, THE PRESIDENT,
AND THE HOUSE SPEAKER, NANCY
PELOSI.
THERE ARE A COUPLE POSTS LIKE
THIS.
IT'S ALARMING AND OF COURSE, IN
SOME WAYS JUST A REGULAR DAY OF
THE WEEK FOR TRUMP.
AND THEN THERE IS WHAT HE SAID
OVER THE WEEKEND AT THE RALLY IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
I WANT TO PLAY THAT AGAIN JUST
BECAUSE IT IS REALLY SHOCKING TO
HEAR ANY PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES DESCRIBE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI IN THIS
VEIN.
>> THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAVE BECOME VICIOUS
MONSTERS CONTROLLED BY RADICAL
LEFT SCOUNDRELS, LAWYERS, AND
THE MEDIA WHO TELL THEM WHAT TO
DO.
>> SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
CRITICISM BY HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY AND OTHERS
WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN USED THE
TERM SEMIFASCIST TO DESCRIBE
THIS TRUMP MAGA MOVEMENT.
BUT WHAT DO YOU CALL IT?
I MEAN, LAW ENFORCEMENT AND YOUR
OPPONENTS, YOUR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS ARE ENEMIES.
THEY TALK ABOUT LOCKING PEOPLE
UP BECAUSE THEY DISAGREE WITH
THEM.
THEY'RE TRYING TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
I'M NOT USING THE TERM FOR IT,
BUT IF SEMIFASCIST ISN'T THE
RIGHT TERM, WHAT IS?
>> I THINK SEMIFASCIST WORKS, I
THINK A LOT OF POLITICAL
SCIENTISTS COULD ARGUE THE
POLITICAL TERM THAT IS BEST, BUT
UNDERNEATH IT ALL IS THIS
MOVEMENT, THIS MIND SET, THIS
DISPOSITION TO ATTACK DEMOCRACY
AND ATTACK TRUTH.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IT'S NOT A SEMANTIC.
KEVIN McCARTHY, TO OBJECT TO
THIS, HE WENT THROUGH, HE WAS A
LAP DOG FOR TRUMP USING THE MOST
EXTREME RHETORIC, INCLUDING WHAT
WE SAW OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> TRUMP HAS CALLED PLENTY OF
PEOPLE FASCISTS, BY THE WAY.
>> EXACTLY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ACTUALLY
QUALIFIED THE SEMIFASCIST
COMMENTS.
HE SAID IT HAD TO DO WITH PEOPLE
WHO CONDONE VIOLENCE, ACTED WITH
VIOLENCE, OR DIDN'T RECOGNIZE AN
ELECTION.
HE WAS CAREFUL IN WHAT HE SAID.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, PEOPLE
LIKE McCARTHY ARE EAGER TO BE
OFFENDED.
THEY'RE ALWAYS GOING ON THE
OFFENSIVE.
THEY'RE LASHING OUT.
THAT'S THE TEMPER AND THE MOOD
OF THE BASE.
AND THEY'RE COWARDS.
THEY'RE HOLLOW MEN, TO USE A
PHRASE FROM T.S. ELLIOTT, AND
THEY'RE DOING WHATEVER THE BASE
WANTS.
THAT COMBINATION OF TRUMP AND A
RADICALIZED BASE AND A TIMID AND
COWARDLY POLITICAL LEADERSHIP IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS CREATED
A REAL DANGER TO DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS A TINDER BOX AND THESE
GUYS ARE USING BLOW TORCHES.
>> WE WANT TO THANK YOU FO